hommage à rosa bonheur et sa famille
durant plus de 50 ans ou dix neuvième
siècle
trois générations d'artistes dans la
famille ont développé leur art de la
peinture animalière à la musique dans la
maison des bonheurs de magny les hameaux
acquises en 1865 pour y installer un
atelier devenu aujourd'hui annexe de la
mairie
le musée de port royal des champs leur
consacre une exposition jusqu'au 25
juillet cette famille dans son ensemble
a à plusieurs talents et donc l'idée
c'est de troncs fronte et ses différents
médiums artistiques de voir comment ces
différents médiums artistiques
finalement créer un art à partir d'
inspiration commune ce monde animalier
qui l'ont vraiment cherché à explorer
sous toute cette forme 70 peintures et
sculptures sont exposées certaines de la
célèbre peintre animalière rosa bonheur
souvent comparée de son temps à jacques
raymond aubrac à ça d'autres de son père
raymond de son frère auguste et les
sculptures de son frère isidore un art
familiale tournée vers la nature et le
monde animalier avec une sensibilité
pour le monde des pâturages et de la
forêt un héritage du père de rosa
bonheur proche de la peinture romantique
ce qui est très intéressant chez eux
c'est que il y a eu un véritable intérêt
pour les spécificités des animaux il ya
vraiment la volonté de s'intéresser très
spécifiquement à la à l'anatomie des
animaux et avec ce côté un peu
positiviste du 19e siècle
si vous voulez et par ailleurs
ils ont pu participé à l'illustration
d'ouvragés scientifiques agricole cette
exposition est une première en france
la majorité des oeuvres de rosa bonheur
se trouvant à londres au metropolitan à
new york pour la réaliser le musée de
port royal a bénéficié de prêts du musée
des beaux-arts de bordeaux du musée de
fontainebleau et de différentes
collections privées